[Music]
Pain
is one of the most trying experiences of
life.
On the cellular level it is communicated
via special neuronal pathways.
On the molecular level however,
pain is communicated like any other sensation-
via a set of electrical and chemical signals
facilitated by complex molecular
machinery.
Along the neuronal membrane, the signal travels much like electric current along a wire.
This process is mediated by membrane proteins
called voltage-gated ion
channels.
Voltage-gated ion channels open or close in reaction to changes in membrane voltage
or membrane potential. These
proteins have special voltage sensing domains
that are coupled to ion channels.
When a neuron is at rest, its ion
channels are closed.
A cell membrane potential is generated
by concentration gradients of positively
charged sodium and potassium ions across the membrane.
When the neuron is at rest, the overall
concentrations of ions and proteins
create higher potential in the outside
and lower on the inside.
This state is referred to as resting
potential and the membrane is said to be polarized.
To transmit signal the neuron creates an
action potential which travels down the axon.
The action potential is mediated by the
opening of the voltage-gated sodium
channels,
which allows sodium to enter the neuron.
This depolarizes the membrane in the
local area.
Neurons then repolarize the membrane in several ways stopping the action potential.
First, voltage-gated sodium channels close and become inactivated.
Then, to counteract the positive charge of the sodium ions,
potassium channels start to open
allowing potassium ions to exit
and lowering the voltage across the membrane.
Finally, after a short refractory period
sodium channels
open the inactivation gates and
ion pumps restore the resting
potential in preparation for the next signal.
In this way the signal travels along the
neuron - sodium channels open and
trigger one another to generate action
potentials
and potassium channels then stop the
action potential in the local area.
Once the action potential arrives at the
end of the neuron,
it is transferred to the next cell at a
place called a synapse.
The synaptic region contains membrane
vesicles filled with
small molecules called neurotransmitters,
which will conduct the signal upon release into the synaptic cleft.
This process is dependent on the
presence of calcium ions inside the cell.
Because intracellular calcium is sparse
while extracellular calcium is abundant,
voltage-gated calcium channels are
essential in this process.
The positive charges of the traveling
action potential activate these proteins
causing the ion channels to open and
allowing calcium inside the cell.
Calcium then activates other proteins
that help the vesicle to merge with the
neuronal membrane,
creating an opening for the
neurotransmitters to enter the synaptic
cleft.
There are many types of
neurotransmitters.
One of them, glutamate, is shown here binding to its receptor.
This receptor has an ion channel which
opens upon glutamate binding
and allows ions to enter the cell
initiating a new action potential that
will travel along the axon, thus allowing the message to be passed along.
These signals can be modulated on the
molecular level causing us to
feel less pain or no pain at all.
Our bodies produce natural painkillers
known as endorphins and enkephalins and dynorphins.
The peptide showed here is an encephalin.
These natural painkillers are mimicked
by opioid drugs.
One of the most widely used opioids is
morphine, which is derived from the opium poppy.
Both natural painkillers and opioids
activate the same inhibitory receptors
called opioid receptors.
Opioid receptors are part of a large
class of g-protein-coupled receptors or
GPCRs.
GPCRs are nested in cellular membranes with the
opioid binding site on the
outside of the cell.
Inside the cell, the receptors are
coupled to G proteins.
G proteins have three distinct subunits
alpha, beta and gamma.
An inactive G protein has GDP bound to its alpha subunit.
Upon opioid binding the GDP is
released, and GTP binds instead,
releasing the g protein from the receptor,
causing the alpha subunit to separate
from the beta and gamma subunits.
The beta-gamma subunit interacts
directly with ion channels,
stopping the signal. For example, the beta gamma subunit can bind to special
potassium channels, causing them to remain open and
allow potassium to exit the cell.
This lowers the electric potential
inside the cell and eventually leads to
the dissipation of the action potential.
The beta gamma subunit can prevent
neurotransmitter release by binding to
voltage-gated calcium channels.
This prevents the activation of the channels.
As a result, calcium is unable to enter the cell,
and the release of neurotransmitters is halted.
There are several types of g-alpha
subunit that couple to different GPCRs.
Two types of G-alpha subunits can
interact with
the enzyme adenylyl cyclase.
These are inhibitory and stimulatory g-alpha.
Opioid receptors are always coupled to
inhibitory g-alpha.
In the presence of stimulatory g-alpha,
adenylyl cyclase uses ATP
to produce cyclic AMP. Cyclic AMP is
often called a second messenger
because it amplifies the signal
generated by the first messengers,
the neurotransmitters.
Cyclic AMP can activate some ion
channels indirectly via protein kinases,
Both activities augment the ion flow regulating the neuronal signal.
0:06:45.440,1193:02:47.295
and activate other ion channels directly.
When opioid receptors are activated, the
G-alpha inhibitory subunit inhibits
adenylyl cyclase, preventing the production of cyclic AMP.
As a result, the signal is dampened.
Opioid drugs are a great boon in pain
management when used for a limited time
and as prescribed by a physician.
However, the possibility of overdose is a danger
as opioids can deactivate neuronal circuits
other than those responsible
for pain signaling,
Causing severe side effects or even
death.
During an overdose, drugs like naloxone
are used to save lives.
Naloxone is similar in structure to
opioids and binds in a similar location
on the receptor, but does not activate
the G protein.
As a result, it makes the receptors
unavailable to opioids.
By studying opioid receptors, scientists
are currently trying to discover
new, non-addictive compounds that can bind to these receptors
in order to create safe painkillers.
[Music]